Між областями  не буде перевезень саме  на першому етапі до початку червня.
Чи варто очікувати підвищення перевізниками цін на квитки?
По залізним перевезенням ми точно не будемо підвищувати ціни на квитки.
Ви висловлювалися  за заборону маршруток.
На жаль,  цей процес за тиждень, звісно, пройти неможливо.
Минулого року багато  говорили про приватизацію Укрзалізниці
Спільно з ВР маємо виконати домашнє завдання,  щоб розпочати процедуру
анбандлінгу  Укрзалізниці,  коли вона розділиться на кількох операторів,
Останнім часом Ви опинилися в центрі  низки скандалів
Три рази фейк.
Навіщо Вам особисто робота в уряді?
Амбіції...
Які пасажирські  автобусні перевезення Україна поновлює в першу чергу?
В першу чергу, весь громадський транспорт всередині міст і внутрішньообласний.
Тобто  в межах області будуть  відбуватися як приміські перевезення,
так і  внутрішньообласні   - автобусні, маршрутні  таксі
і, власне, всіма видами транспорту.
Між областями не буде перевезень саме  на першому етапі до початку червня.
З тією метою, щоб перевірити, як впроваджуються ті заходи,
як ситуація залишається контрольованою.
Тому що інакше буде дуже важко  зрозуміти – епідемія, звідки, куди мігрує
і якби тут  наражати на додаткові ризики не бажано.
Тому  весь цей запуск він буде відбуватися  поетапно.
Яких санітарних правил мають дотримуватися перевізники?
І як здійснюватиметься контроль, за їх дотриманням?
Поліція плюс державна служба з безпеки на транспорті.
Це  наші координації.
Які правила?
Дезінфекція, температурний скринінг, засоби індивідуального захисту у персоналу
- у водіїв, і звісно, що контроль, в тому числі, індивідуального захисту - масок у пасажирів.
Як ви думаєте, як довго Україна може тримати відкритими метрополітени?
Наскільки там може погіршитися ситуація?
За якими правилами метрополітени знов можуть розпочати роботу?
Правила вони однакові для всього громадського транспорту - обов’язкова постійна дезінфекція.
Це те, що на рівні відповідальності керівництва метрополітенів.
Це контроль за масковим режимом і за можливістю
- це рекомендація, але температурний скринінг.
Більше того, є технічні засоби, які теж можна закупити на рівні міст.
На превеликий жаль, обмежити кількість у вагонах
- контрольовано і організовано -  доволі важко
Бажано все для цього зробити, щоб, принаймні, не більше,
ніж кількість посадкових місць у вагонах заходило пасажирів у вагон.
"Укрзалізниця" спочатку запустить приміські електрички, потім вже міжобласні потяги.
Для нічних потягів будуть якісь особливі правила?
В літку, коли буде спекотно, тому тут важливо, щоб кондиціонери,
система кондиціонування була запущена
і працювали відповідно у наших вагонах пасажирських.
Як варіант можливий, - обмежена кількість пасажирів,  як в деяких країнах робили,
коли тільки одна друга завантажується і тоді менше ризиків, власне,
для того, щоб в купе або плацкарті сідали.
І другий варіант - це розміщення сім’ями.
Якщо, наприклад, родина, то без обмежень. Вся родина може заїхати в купе.
Якщо це люди не з однієї сім’ї, то тоді можуть бути обмеження.
Але знов таки, до цього етапу ми ще підійдемо.
Думаю, що ми з міністерством охорони здоров’я більше детально протягом тижня це опрацюємо.
Ви підрахували, що щомісячні втрати авіаперевізників
через зупинку під час карантину складають більше 600 млн грв.
Чи є підрахунки втрат автобусних перевізників та залізниці?
По залізниці можна казати, що за перший квартал в нас 7 млрд. грн. збитків було.
І в нас є спад по вантажопотоку і пасажиропотоку, він фактично взагалі зупинився.
Що стосується автобусних перевезень, у нас єдиної статистики немає.
Але, зрозуміло, що багато компаній -  ми з перевізниками збиралися -
вони фактично теж зупинили свою діяльність .
Яким може або буде компенсатор цих втрат у транспортній галузі?
І чи варто очікувати підвищення перевізниками цін на квитки?
По залізничним перевезенням ми точно не будемо підвищувати ціни на квитки.
Міський транспорт, зрозуміло, ціни на квитки не будуть підвищуватися .
Думаю, що внутрішньообласний і міський – там де маршрутні таксі,
вони теж певну ціну заявили, тому вони не будуть збільшувати.
Єдине, що по авіаперевізникам буде дуже недолуго
і неправильно збільшувати вартість  авіаперевезень,
тому що і так коло людей буде менше.
І якщо ми хочемо швидше відновити роботу транспорту, навпаки це має бути доступні ціни,
для того,  щоб от цей психологічний бар’єр і вихід з карантину -
поетапний, швидше можна було подолати.
Раніше Ви висловлювалися  за заборону маршруток.
Після  карантину цей транспорт знов вийде на маршрути.
Якщо їх таки заборонити, то треба поставити щось натомість.
Скільки часу і коштів необхідно аби замінити маршрутки якісним транспортом?
Кожне місто має свої різні потреби і вони мають свої потреби формувати,
і законопроєкт про транспорту послугу зараз нами розробляється.
Нажаль,  цей процес за тиждень і за місяць, звісно, пройти неможливо.
Але ми маємо до цього прийти, коли ті ж самі власники маршрутних таксі,
які там оперують на певних напрямках і виграли за результатами конкурсів
якісь маршрути,  їх обслуговують, вони зможуть перейти на автобуси,
на електробуси, на тролейбуси.
Україна може виробляти свій електричний транспорт,  Е-буси, приміром
Чому ці програми не просуваються?
По електробусам є програми, але знов таки,
вони мають находити попит і має бути клієнт – замовник.
Наразі міста в обмеженій кількості замовляють,
тому що це комунальні підприємства, вони обслуговують,
а більшість до сих пір оперують за рахунок маршрутних таксі.
От, власне, повертаючись до нашого законопроєкту, я переконаний,
якщо буде прийнято,  в нас стрімко почне розвиватися ринок виробництва,
в тому числі, електробусів і нових  автобусів.
Минулого року багато говорили про приватизацію" Укрзалізниці".
Як виглядає наразі план уряду щодо цієї державної компанії?
Про приватизацію "Укрзалізниці" ми ніколи не говорили.
Ми говорили про те,  що компанія,  як публічна, вона може виходити на фондовий ринок,
де буде торгівля цінним паперами, робити публічне розміщення.
Після чого ставати ще більше відкритою.
Плюс залучити частину грошей, конвертуючи там свої акції в певні активи,
і покращувати стан рухомого складу, наприклад, або інфраструктури.
Наразі карантин вносить свої корективи.
Будемо зміщати на більш піздні терміни
Зараз спільно з ВР маємо виконати домашнє завдання,
щоб розпочати процедуру андбандлінгу "Укрзалізниці",
коли вона розділиться на кількох операторів, з різними ключовими завданнями:
ті, хто будуть управляти пасажирськими перевезеннями,
ті, хто будуть управляти вантажоперевезеннями та інфраструктурою.
Ви думаєте, що цей план є ефективним на тлі того, що в "Укрзалізниці"
багато застарілих потягів?
От, власне, тут і питання.
Жоден банк – ЄБРР, міжнародні фінансові організації
ніколи не виділяють ресурс на пасажирські перевезення,
тому що це збитковий вид діяльності.
Виходячи з цього, треба розуміти, хто може утримувати?
Ми можемо з бюджету на оновлення рухомого складу пасажирського
власне отримувати фінансування з бюджету.
Що стосується вантажних перевезень, то там, зрозуміло,
традиційно там і розміщення публічне акцій може бути, і кредити залучені різноманітні,
програми з нашими фінансовими партнерами. Там це все цілком можливо.
Ви казали, що перемовини про співпрацю "Укрзалізници"
з німецьким концерном Deutsche Bahn  відкладаються на невизначений термін.
Чому? Україні не пасують німецькі правила?
Україні пасують дуже німецькі правила.
Ми обов’язково продовжимо цю співпрацю, але той консалтинг, який об’явили на 80 млн. грн.
зараз необхідно трохи  трансформацією займатися,
але і більш компактно, і менш витратно
Після зняття карантинних обмежень, я впевнений, що Укрзалізниця
продовжить роботу по консалтингу
Більше того, Deutsche Bahn - консалтинг, інжиніринг, вони вже працювали і працюють,
наприклад, над вибором постачальників по електровозам.
Електровози іноземного виробництва?
Да. В нас немає електровозів наразі в Україні, не виробляються, нажаль, електровози.
Єдине підприємство, яке виробляло в свій час електровози - це "ДЕВЗУ"  в Дніпропетровську.
Поки що це державне підприємство знаходиться в запущеному стані.
І це така наша велика мрія відновити і, в тому числі,
щоб електровози могли вироблятися, як раніше.
Ви прихильник здачі в концесію морських портів? Чи є вже успіхи від перших контрактів?
Ми провели два концесійні конкурси. Один - це по херсонському торгівельному порту.
Там концесіонер виборов право заплатити до 300 млн. грн. інвестицій в розвиток регіону
і, власне, сплачувати щорічний  концесійний платіж понад 12 млн. грн.
при тому, що порт був збитковий.
Що стосується спеціального торгівельного морського порту "Ольвія",
то в нас там виграла катарська компанія QTerminals.
Це взагалі найбільша пряма інвестиція у морську галузь - 3,4 млрд. грн. інвестицій.
Це теж розвиває регіон.
Останнім часом Ви опинилися в центрі низки скандалів,
Вам закидають створення корупційних схем в транспортній галузі.
Вами нібито цікавиться ДБР. І Ви навіть готові подати у відставку.
Це означає, що обвинувачення справедливі чи ні?
Це означає, що три рази фейк. З усього озвученого.
Почнемо з низки скандалів. Як правило, вони всі адресні.
Дивіться першеджерело. Це написав вельмишановний пан Дубинський.
Так саме він написав, що я 4 мільйони заробив на повернені і евакуації громадян України.
Це, як раз мова про рейси, де нічого не виплатили
і ще опрацьовується ця інформація в мінекономіки.
Стосовно того, що там з газобалонним обладнанням і решта, решта…
купа великих питань.
Все першоджерело- це виключно він.
Запитайте в нього. Той хто писав, хай надає інформацію.
Він звернувся до правоохоронних оргарнів - нехай відпрацьовують.
Стосовно зацікавленості від правоохоронців
Нікуди ще не запрошували, не перевіряли жодних запитів, жодних активностей, нічого.
Тому, можу стверджувати, що точно тут це все просто виноситься в інформаційне поле
аби намагатися створити таку медіа атаку по відношенню до міністра інфраструктури,
який точно не пов’язаний з жодною  фінансово-промисловою групою.
Вам 33 роки. Вас чомусь називають мільйонером. Чому?
Я працював раніше в інвестиційному бізнесі.
Декларація демонструє статки - ніякої закритої інформації.
Навіщо Вам особисто робота в уряді?
Амбіції. І можливості реалізувати речі якісь на іншому масштабі.
Я займався відповідальною реформою сервізних центрів МВС,
ми ліквідовували підрозділи МРЕО та ДАІ,
а зараз це зручні, затишні, комфортні, зрозумілі, зі зручними сервісами процедури.
Треба масштабувати подібні речі на інший рівень.
Цифрові коридори електроні, цифрові порти,
цифровий обмін інформацією з іншими країнами,
з перевізниками і весь контроль без бюрократії і чиновників - це все реально.
І ми в цьому напрямку, власне, рухаємося.
Тому, я думаю, що до кінця року ви побачити ще багато перемог.
Дуже дякую.
І вам дякую.